zunächst dabei haben sie recht hinter
diese kritische ereignisse dritte japan
nämlich wirklich zurück auch bewusstsein
der bedeutung für den menschen
gleichwohl hat sich die produktion jetzt
behauptet werden nicht eingesetzt
nächste woche zu verabschieden
was noch bei einem nächsten vater in
kraft treten soll und das wird nicht
dazu führen dass wir am 20 märz
weitesten normalität zurückkehren es
gibt keinerlei beschränkungen werden
andere parteien lägen bei betrieben wenn
die länder sind in der lage das
geschichten anzuordnen wenn sie es für
notwendig erachten für altenpflegeheime
testungen für altenpflege eine
krankenhäuser und auch schulen wenn sie
wie gesagt dass wir möglichkeiten und es
gibt die möglichkeit
dass
diese könnten freigegeben danach nahm
aber davon sich momentan brauchst du
gehen seehofer ergänzte aber keine
zukäufe mehr zu den krankenhäusern
beziehungsweise funkstationen angesicht
der tatsache dass wir am 20 märz
weitgehend normalität zurückkehren so
laut dass man eigentlich nur haupt
gefunden denn
und dass wir sie als einziges
demokratisches land einführen weil ich
für ausgeschlossen dafür wird im
deutschen bundestag eine mehrheit gegen
zu werden beruhigte sich die situation
etwas wird ehrenamt von der angst
getrieben in fahrt bringt ihn zu einer
vernünftigen mit maßnahmen zu reagieren
es notwendig ist aber nichts auf vorrat
zu produzieren was dazu führen kann dass
die menschen weiter ängstlich sind und
jedes leben führen können also die
impfpflicht die muss spätestens jetzt
vom tisch sein jan fleischhauer sehen
sie als außerdem überhaupt noch
irgendeine chance dass sie kommt sowieso
in vergessenheit geraten ich dachte dass
wir die ganze zeit der plan der
bundesregierung
nochmals alle kräfte zu schieben dass
man dass er sich von selbst erledigt ich
mann er hat ja im ersten schritt glaube
ich dass es eine gewissensentscheidung
der abgeordneten gemacht unter sich wie
kubicki also ich glaube nicht dass ich
dafür jetzt eine mehrheit im bundestag
findet jedenfalls für eine sache die
doch
weil die leute nach wie vor hoch
umstritten ist aber dennoch man hält
daran fest also wie
das kriegt weil jetzt bundestag ein und
dann fällt
wie ins große loch fällt einfach
irgendwie haben wir nie gesagt wäre doch
ob ihr dann hat man ob man gezeigt man
wollte das richtige und ja
das thema ist doch wie gesagt also auch
crooner mit allem drum und dran also
herr lauterbach warnt er tapfer
jede woche von neuen wellen ich glaube
jetzt vor der sechsten oder wir sind in
der sechsten und die fand er vor der
siebten und dann kommt man der
sommerrallye oder kubicki die wahl
welche ja ja so ne also und ich hab
jetzt starb vor in der letzten woche
sich doch hier gibt es im terminkalender
für journalisten wichtige termine allem
einzige oben stand robert wieder karl
lauterbach der gesundheitsminister
informieren über die gronauer lager
wurde der termin abgesagt wegen
mangelndem interesse so dass da stehen
wir heute und muss man mal sagen gott
lob aber dennoch herr kubicki ihre
partei sieht das genauso wie sie also
glauben sie auch dass vonseiten fdp
keiner bekomme sagt da war doch mal was
mit der in sicht sollten wir nicht
wollten wir nicht ich kann nur sagen ich
kann nur sagen es eine deutliche
mehrheit in meiner fraktion dass du
sieht wie ich es gibt auch kollegen und
kollegen die für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht rotieren ganz wenige und es
gibt überlegungen kollegen und der frage
wie man die für alle impfpflicht 50
notieren aus meiner sicht macht es
keinen sinn mehr denn die stille und
gepolsterte könnte es genauso infizieren
und infektionsträger sagen wir und gifte
wir haben riesen instanzen und es kommt
auch keine ungenutzten mehr bei den
intensivstationen insofern nach die
impfpflicht keinen sinn und dass wir uns
vor einer welle von der dauer will ihn
von karlotta wilde schützen müssen mit
einem stock die wir noch gar nicht
kennen halte ich für rechtsstaatlich
kaum vertreter von eigentlich würden
nicht mehr viel kommunizieren bei ihr ab
20 mehr als alle beschränkenden regeln
im normalen täglichen leben nicht mehr
haben wird es gibt keine massen kriegt
wer keine abstand 2 3 gegen die regeln
wir können das mit almen wirklich die
menschen wieder treffen bei
veranstaltungen jeder grösse brauche
wenn wir das so machen und das wird
nächsten donnerstag geschlossen werden
dann macht die annehmlichkeiten sind auf
vorrat woran wir mittlerweile auch
wissen ich bin doch deutlich ältere
generation muss man sagen dass der
schutz der durch die impfung erfolgt
auch für mich selbst nur von begrenzter
dabei ist und es gar keine fremdschutz
mehr gibt bei einer impfung für dritte
personen weil wir wie gesagt selbst als
geben sich der infektionsträger sein
würden dennoch haben wir ja die ganze
zeit jetzt auch über monate gehört die
impfung sie muss weiter nach oben gehen
vor allem die ddr 10.50 noch nicht
abgeholt haben die zweitimpfung noch
nicht abholte doch gar nicht an den
booster denken das sind die zahlen die
es endlich nach oben gehen dass wir
dieses ganze ding ist unter den tisch
fallen und dann surfen wir in den winter
reihen von denen jeder wand und sagen ja
ja gut ist haben wir das irgendwie am
anfang des jahres nicht so richtig hier
auf die kette bekommen machen jetzt noch
so skurril das klingen mag aber die am
besten geschützten sind die gegner sich
infiziert haben werden die sind jetzt
tatsächlich
natürliche immunität versehen die
längere zeit auch anhält und die auch
verschiedene varianten identifizieren
können also das ist wirklich ein
treppenwitz der geschichte dass
ausgerechnet die dieses geweigert haben
aber infiziert haben nun am besten
geschützt sind ich glaube aber anders
gesehen oder wie wir das hat das lka war
anders erklärt interessanterweise sind
sie von diesem thema unter das war bei
der data variante noch etwas anderes
erstmalig konnte aber wenn sie virologen
hören und fragen sie hätten sich stets
das weiß ja sagt das auch regelmäßig
auch christian drosten hat das podcast
beim ndr habe gesagt
dabei dann ist das eine frage der
eigenen risikoeinschätzung kann man sich
impfen lassen oder nicht ich plädiere
dafür
ich habe ein richtig gutes gefühl gehabt
nach der info weil ich mir gedacht habe
das musst du keine angst mehr vor der
infektion haben aber das sollen die
leute im zweifel selbst entscheiden sie
zu verpflichten
hinhaltenden widerstand von ihnen gesagt
habe ihnen gruppen halte ich für nicht
durchsetzbar in dieser republik aber wie
soll das dann durchsetzbar sein sie sagt
jetzt auch beide ja das wird man so ein
bisschen unter den tisch fallen lassen
das wird sich aus denn noch haben wir ja
auch immer wieder im bundeskanzler jetzt
auch noch mal gesagt hat er hält daran
fest so wie kann man das durchziehen
ohne dass man dann öffentlich benennen
es macht jetzt keinen sinn weil wir
schauen uns an also sehr schön die leute
sagen es macht keinen sinn wir aber wie
kommt man aus der nummer raus als bundes
durch abstimmung im deutschen bundestag
wir werden immer in der ersten
aprilwoche darüber abstimmen und dann
werden wir feststellen wo die mehrheiten
und wie die mehrheiten sind ich sage ja
gesagt ich kann mir momentan nicht
vorstellen dass es eine mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag endlich gibt ich
kann das aber auch nicht ausschließen
aber
für sehr wahrscheinlich dann werden
ihnen dann wird dieses gesetzentwurf zur
einführung der helmpflicht schlicht und
ergreifend nicht beschlossen und dann
gibt es gar nicht also war ja lange
finanzminister unsere angela merkel und
hatte sich das ein oder andere abgeguckt
und wenn wir uns erinnern angela merkel
war immer ganz großem warnen ja und dann
sagst in diesem
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat gerade
so schlimm mit den zahlen wir müssen
unbedingt was machen und dann hat sie
das auch in pressekonferenzen vertreten
hat gehört ich konnte mich leider nicht
durchsetzen das hat ihr nie jemand als
führungsschwäche ausgelegt sondern immer
wenn es dann nachher wieder hoch ging
die frau merkel hat rechtzeitig gewarnt
und dieser effekt wird auch bei olaf
scholz einsetzen das heißt er war für
die dokumentiert für die impfpflicht und
wenn dann die zahlen jetzt im winter
wieder steigen wird er sagen freunde ich
hab's euch gesagt
das ist also dann die takte geben die
man vorgibt also ich konnte mich leider
nicht durch das sehr kubicki glauben sie
dass die strategie sein wird glauben wir
dass wir genau das erleben werden was
herr fleischer oder zeichnet ich vermute
dass sie ähnlich wie bei tutti gar keine
wirkliche strategie dahinter steckt
momentan was die pflicht angeht ist er
denn bis zur bundestagswahl und die drei
wochen noch danach war ja oder spritzig
wie alle anderen auch gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht und andere besser
erkenntnis die sich ja nicht gewartet
hat ihren sohn zu einem und her bewegt
und ihnen erklären lassen herr rolle
jetzt die allgemeine impfpflicht
ich glaube das wird genauso passieren
die ihn mit angela merkel fleisch oder
bei der frage für alle ist ja gesagt sie
sei dagegen hat die abstimmung
freigegeben hat dann gegen die gier für
alle gestimmt und trotzdem bisschen
gekommen hier war es umgekehrt sein hier
werden wir feststellen dass oder schuld
feststellt die abgeordneten haben sich
so entschieden das ist parlamentarismus
das ist unsere verfassung die das
vorgibt und dieselmotor beuge ich mich
jetzt ich habe andere überzeugen drei
kenntnisse aber gleichwohl in einer
demokratie entscheidet die mehrheit im
parlament wissen sie was das sollte auch
ein coupé das tolle ist bei dieser
entscheidung auf diese gar zu sprechen
kommt mit der ehe für alle wenn sie
heute leute fragen dann 90 prozent
würden schwören die angela war natürlich
für die ehe wie wir alle es
kann von frau merkel will in du hättest
aber sagen dass ja also erst mal
widersprechen kann ich herrn kubicki
nicht weil ich sehe es mit der ich ganz
genauso mit der aktuellen variante des
virus glaube ich gibt es da überhaupt
gar keine notwendigkeit ich will aber
noch mal auf diese auf diese wahrnehmung
zurückkommen also ich hab grad normal
hinguckt
262.000 neuinfektionen hatten wir
gestern
hätten wir das vor einer vor zwei wochen
gehabt oder vor zwei monaten oder oder
vor zwei jahren werden explodiert alle
wir hätten ja wir hatten ja was und ich
möchte auch gar nicht an die data
variante am sonntag war wesentlich auch
glaube ich habe auch vor einem monat
hätten wir doch wer hat noch nur darüber
berichtet und auch wir jetzt mal ja als
bild ja wir hätten gesagt unglaublich
die höchste instanz jemals und so viele
und insofern finde ich schon wirklich
spannend wie dieses thema aus der
wahrnehmung so so schnell verschwunden
ist halte ich hab gehört nicht mal mehr
bei den pressekonferenzen des
gesundheitsministers kriegt man genug
interesse dafür
ich glaube da sollten wir auch als
medien dann in dem fall uns mal wissen
selbst an die nase greifen also ja die
politik hat eine sehr sehr große
mitverantwortung wie das die thema
gehandhabt wird aber ich glaube die
medien und die öffentlichkeit die wir
brauchten auch immer irgendwas wir
wollten uns auch irgendwas meisten leute
haben sozialisten haben sie auch gelesen
die artikel ja wenn ich eine
viertelmillion gestern da dreht auch
meine oma erst mal durch ja aber wenn
wir jetzt sehen das thema wurde so
unfassbar schnell irgendwie aus der
ersten reihe verbannt und wurde durch
ein anderes abgedeckt abwehr hatte schon
zwei jahre beschäftigt das stimmt das
schön aber sagen wir so wir haben jetzt
eine weltpolitische krise die uns auch
wieder an der tankstelle und so weiter
betrifft also insofern sehen wir ja das
ist ja nicht nur irgendwo in der ukraine
ist sondern wir sehen da die auswirkung
glaube ich bei jedem ihrer gasrechnung
zum beispiel insofern sehen wir das
jetzt eine andere krise da ist und man
kann nur hoffen dass auch von den
varianten her omikron und
möglichst lange erhalten bleibt wenn man
so möchte und wir nicht irgendwie jetzt
dieses datacon oder was auch immer
bekommen wofür er laut da war er warnt
und das ist eben so bleibt dass wir wohl
in sidenten haben aber geringe kanten
aussagen geringe todeszahlen haben und
uns endlich wieder auf die wichtigen
dinge des lebens konzentrieren aber das
lustige ist einige experten schon jetzt
schon um
also ich habe die leopoldina zum
beispiel erinnern das loch im letzten
winter her so dass jetzt an
sofortmaßnahmen sein muss ja weil sonst
wenn die sofortmaßnahmen durchkommen
alles ganz schrecklich
diese woche erneut stellungnahme der
leopoldina diesmal
wenn sich deutschland vom gas und öl
abkoppelt überhaupt kein problem ja wir
haben das durchgerechnet also wieder so
modelliert ja da gibt es den kleinen
unwucht wirtschaftssystem aber im
prinzip wir kriegen das hin soll also
die leopoldina fragen zu allen christen
studien
kurz ergänzen wollen wir das wirklich am
herzen liegt das ist ein unterschied ob
mini data variante reden oder
reden denn wir hatten tatsächlich eine
situation wo selbst ich die befürchtung
hatte unser gesundheitssystem könnte
durch die welle tatsächlich überlastet
wird das haben wir momentan nicht wir
haben diesen lizenzen und trotzdem kann
die zugänge zu den krankenhäusern was
darauf hindeutet dass auch bei den
ungeimpften die omikron infizierung
leichter verläuft als es in der
vergangenheit der frage wie es ist wir
können von glück sagen was wollen sie
diese situation befinden und lassen sich
auch sagen wenn sich jetzt alle
infizieren würden wie alle
eingeschlossen wie er dadurch auch ein
natürlich mitbekommen würden dann so
christian drosten werden mit dem thema
durch auch was im winter den nachbarn
peter angeht und ich hoffe und vermutet
dass auch das ist gar nicht wer variante
geben wird denn wie gesagt die hohe
infektionszahlen deuten daraufhin dass
virus verbreitet sich als objekt
verwandelt was wie schnell es führt zu
einer natürlichen immunität der
gesamtbevölkerung mit infront genesenen
status und dann waren wir im herbst auf
das problem nicht mehr so fern können
wir jetzt von der impfpflicht abstand
nehmen jeder der sich impfen lassen will
sollte das tun ich rate auch noch dazu
dass auf jeden fall zu tun aber bis
heute niemand mehr dazu verpflichten
abgesehen davon dass wir es auch gar
nicht durchsetzen könnten im endergebnis